ah thank you so much
look I'll be honest I am NOT a political
comedian really but I do watch a lot of
news on television and I've noticed
lately that President Obama looks very
sad you know he looks depressed I feel
like every morning when Obama wakes up
he goes to his bathroom mirror and says
to himself you know no matter what I do
no matter what I try to accomplish Will
Smith's just gonna play me in my stupid
movies so what's the point what if you
can tell from my glasses but I am a
Jewish person thank you glad you don't
be Jewish it's like anything it has its
pros and cons it's not all glamour like
it does it has its benefits like for
example I'm gonna win an Emmy at some
point I'm gonna win an Emmy and that's
fine I'm fine with that but the downside
is I'm never gonna dunk a basketball or
feel comfortable and a convertible ever
we're know what heaven feels like
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's okay don't worry about it this is
sort of the worst time of year for Jews
oh happy Chanukah by the way nice
personally Hanukkah but the holiday
season is rough for Jews because
Hanukkah I don't if you know this but
Hanukkah
it by itself is a very minor holiday
totally lame and that's exacerbated by
the fact that everyone tries to put it
on equal footing with Christmas like
that's a fair comparison
no Christmas wins hands down I'm much
better holiday like you guys know the
story of Hanukkah silence okay Hanukkah
is a holiday where we remember the
Maccabees and the Maccabees were these
Jews thousands of years ago who got
locked inside the temple and downtown
Jerusalem or whatever couldn't get out
so they were forced to ration lamp oil
for a week the end that's it that's it
that's Annika yeah I really want to
compare that to Christmas wait what's
Christmas again oh that's right God's
birthday party it's a birthday party for
Jesus are you kidding that's amazing
that's like going to Oprah's birthday
party the same principle everyone gets
presents just for showing up oh my god
thank you you're so nice yeah I'll read
whatever books you tell me to
and if I sound bitter that's only
because I'm super bitter I wanted I
wanted to celebrate Christmas so bad
when I was a kid you know you have to
understand what it looks like from an
outsider's perspective not only do you
get a bunch of presents but you get to
wear funny sweaters and sing silly songs
and you put rum in your eggnog
and then you go outside and chop down a
tree bring that tree into your living
room and just everyone stands around and
watches that tree die when someone is
like yo that trees boring let's put a
bunch of light bulbs and popcorn and
dangerous balls of glass all over it and
I'm gonna go hang socks on my fireplace
you know and everyone's like that sounds
like a fire hazard but go for it you
sound excited then he hangs a plan on
the ceiling he's like hey I'm standing
under a plan to get to make out with you
now something like making out this dude
and then I gave me the knife some fat
dude you don't even know breaks into
your house through your chimney raves
your refrigerator you're like psyched
about the next thing just drinking and
dancing and decorating it sounds like a
gay frat party you know I said oh god
can't compare that to Hanukkah do you
know how you celebrate Hanukkah this is
what you do I'm gonna lift the curtain
first of all you sit at a table with
your family so already you light a bunch
of candles spin a wooden top and watch
your grandma slowly fall asleep eating
hash for us
I forgot to mention if you have for
eight nights in a row
that's the bun twist it just doesn't end
I remember when I was like six years old
I found out about Easter and my head
almost exploded I was so jealous I was
hang out I was hang out my Gentile
friend complaining about Christmas I was
like oh that's so cool that Christmas is
your holiest holiday he just looked at
me like no dude Easter Easter Sarkozy's
holiday knob viously I was just like
what the hell is Easter and he was like
oh Easter um yeah that's just another
birthday party for Jesus I was like what
another birthday party how does that
even work and he was like oh well we
believe we believe you guys killed Jesus
and then three days later he came back
to life and we just pig out on candy
so obviously I was offended by that and
I was just like are you kidding me
you guys have a zombie birthday party
that is the coolest thing I've ever
heard
I gotta go home and eat past rounds with
my me mean
[Applause]